I want to start off this episode by
issuing an a public apology
and my basically I owe an apology to all
white men
and in the last two episodes
um well a couple episodes ago now I
basically said that I'm not attracted to
white men and I feel like I heard a lot
of people's feelings and I just want to
say like
just not
I I'm not in that that's not currently
like my era like but I I'm not
um I am open to it you're not ruling it
out for the future I'm not ruling it out
I certainly haven't ruled it out in the
past like I've been with white boys okay
just you know for the next you know
foreseeable couple weeks it's just not
in my rotation as of now listen she
changes the race that she's attracted to
per week so thank you stay patient
that's what I'm doing
I would also like to issue an apology to
white men I am sorry I am jealous of you
I wish I could get a woman pregnant and
I'm struggling with that and sometimes I
take it out on you guys so I would like
to formally apologize
I've been very nice to white men I have
nothing else to say
[Music]
thicker healthier hair
Port our show go to neutrophone.com and
enter code trash to save ten dollars off
your first month subscription get ten
dollars off at neutrophone.com spelled
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l.com promo code trash
free shipping on every order offer only
available to us customers for a limited
time this episode is brought to you by
simply spiked go to drinksimplyspike.com
trash Tuesday to find out how to get
your hands on simply Spike lemonade and
new simply Spike Peach that's
drinksimplyspike.com trash Tuesday
flavored beer naturally flavored with
other natural flavors simply spyco
Milwaukee Wisconsin celebrate
responsibly simply Spike this a
trademark of the Simply Orange Juice
company hey sluggies I'm so excited you
can see me in San Antonio Texas next
weekend on the 23rd it's a couple
weekends from now 23rd to the 24th
um I'm also going to be in Philadelphia
in August and I have
um I will be in Canada I will be in
um San Francisco San Jose and Austin
Texas October 6th and 7th so go to
annieleterman.com shows to get tickets
for all of those and uh every Thursday
you can see me on my solo podcast
anniewood it's been so fun we can't wait
to see you there
hi slugs I'm so excited that I am back
on the road doing stand up it's been so
much fun laughing and being weird with
all of you guys and I will be in New
York City at Joe's Pub July 19th through
22nd I will be at the DC Improv
September 28th and at the Wilbur in
Boston September 30th get tickets at
Esther onice.com I know I'm adding more
shows I'll see you guys there
thank you
Welcome to our 80s workout themed
episode I know this looks really festive
and happy but I'm sweating and I I'm
fully triggered I don't know if you guys
know this but I spent my entire
childhood part of the physical abuse
that I endured was that my mom made me
do Jane Fonda and Susan Harris The Firm
workouts on VHS for Like A decade
is like an another reminder of your
abuse I'm twitching I'm honestly I came
in I was like
like I'm gonna start rocking pretty soon
because this was my entire childhood and
everyone remembers it so fondly but Jane
Fonda fondantly
Jane Fonda The Challenge
is an hour and a half workout
and it was one that on like an hour and
a half an hour and a half tried Jane
Fonda challenge it's great they have a a
dance routine they have an arm routine
they have a floor routine they have all
the Pilates moves it's it's hard and
there's Susan Harris
The Firm
The Firm it's called the great workout
whether she's wearing yellow I don't
know these I just want to know what
state was our country in that this is
the way women were dressing like this is
thank you it is I think people fashion
follows drugs right oh is this very
cocaine I think so I see that there you
go Susan Harris like this wasn't much of
an ass girl was she
I find this to be the most repulsive
aesthetic currently like you know how
the trends go in waves like I feel like
right now we're doing this at the exact
moment where this is just the most
unattractive undesired this is
unattractive to you
um all the things you wear
this is my least favorite but I guess
it's just a little vaginal like you're
like wait so Annie you are the only one
of us that didn't order a costume you
had this lying around I had a custom
ordered I said sometimes it doesn't work
out and um
I looked in my
I have like sorry I'm eating a starburst
it's so disrespectful but it was all
they were all pink ones anyway
I saw them uh they just were sitting
there I just had these skims I ordered
on a whim a skim swim you know how that
goes
haven't worn them yet and this is the
skims too and I just thought oh my god
oh the pants are skims too everything
skims oh and then I had these Donuts
these Danny donut DeVito
socks that a fan gave me in Texas
those are great Reeboks and then the
Reeboks were free baby thank you all the
company that bought um
juicy sent them to me thank you love you
send me more things I'm um I'm wearing
this shirt and I'm not
um showing you my full outfit because
again bulk face arms are a little bit
thick right now so isn't that a good
thing
yeah just not on camera
I'll go flex in my own private life I'll
I'm flexing my bulk face how do we feel
you pretty good
you know what it is just the triceps
it's a it's the full back of the arm
very strong yeah very strong koyla
tattoo accentuated beautifully
um which Speaking of while we're doing
formal apologies I do want to formally
apologize to in public for getting your
name tattooed on my body I do think that
there must be times where that makes you
uncomfortable and I just in case it does
I want to say I'm sorry
um this is gonna hurt you even more God
about it basically right honestly that's
great I don't think about it I when I
see it I'm like oh that's a tattoo I
never crosses my mind people telling me
that they don't think about me is the
greatest option always like that's the
isn't that the best version of things
always I don't know well if you well it
depends because if you've built up a
story where they're like plotting
against you and then they're like oh you
just weren't thinking about me all
that's definitely the best case scenario
but if it's like a loved one I'm like I
hope you're thinking about me a little
bit not for me you want no one to think
of you yeah
I'm actually wearing a skims push-up bra
today I finally got to try it out so
this is exciting for me and my costume
is by
the designer Jeff Bezos heard of him
Jeffy thank you Jeffrey do you want
people to be thinking about you or not
thinking about you um
I don't want to have to think if people
are thinking about me period yeah
um you know I think I've done that so
much in my life and it's backfired every
like my entire life where you like think
you know yeah it's never you're always
like that's what you think it's like a
this is a famous phenomenon it's called
the spotlight effect it's like that we
as humans always overestimate the amount
that others are thinking about us it's
just like a part of human nature we
always will overestimate that
but but have you ever like kind of
gotten the vibe from someone like like
there's one girl where I'm like oh her
boyfriend hears my name a lot like you
know the girls are kind of like wait
what do you mean you know like in comedy
they'll be like a younger comic who kind
of like you can like oh did you get like
obsessed with me like they get like a
mesh with your career oh when you said
your boyfriend says here
imagining her like God this one girl
wants like approached me when she was
drunk and gave me too much information
like it was like oh we've never been
this close but see I've done that like I
recently met someone who I'm a fan of
and I think I did take it too far it's
this guy Max lugavier who's podcast I
listen to religiously and I was like
you're so great like you killed it on
Joe Rogan like you're really like
fighting the good fight and I and I
walked away from that interaction was
like
that man should be scared of me I said
way too much to no you were a nice fan I
think that's good okay and I think
people appreciate that but when a fan
knows too much I'm like but it's not a
fan this is someone you work with I
don't work with him no but I'm saying
what I was saying is like this is like
someone that you like that you like see
around the club and you go like oh I
don't think about this is not a person
that's in my Orbit and then they come to
you with so much intensity one night
where you go oh my God I like your you
talk about me to your boyfriend a lot
you're saying you're entangled you're a
meshed
uh interesting I don't know if it's a
good thing or a bad thing you know like
sometimes people get like the poison
when you're younger in your career get
like the poison for someone else and
their career feels like when they get
things you like notice it more
interesting I have a question to
um both of you um Jewish girls
um and my question is can an ex-catholic
[__]
um convert or be accepted into Judaism
yes we accept everyone are you sure how
sure are we
because I'm I've been watching um Jewish
matchmaking on Netflix I know I saw it I
haven't watched it but I saw it there
and you know I go through the whole
Indian matchmaking I watch all like the
dating shows basically and um there's a
part of me that I I don't know what it
is but I have Jewish Envy like real
Jewish Envy I think a lot of people do
it's real wait what is your envy that
you want to be with a Jewish man or you
want to be Jewish I like Shabbat I like
a lot of the ideals I like
um
um I love hearing or listening to Hebrew
like I it's like a lot about it like I'm
magnetized too but I just don't know if
I'm going to be accepted okay well
Jewish people don't like listening to
Hebrew so that is an issue like I feel
like every Jewish guy I know like that
hated Hebrew school would cringe at you
saying that like that's crazy so am I
fetishizing no I'm but yeah you're
fochata sizing
this is what I've always felt like about
the Jewish culture it's like we accept
open arms like if you we hate ourselves
so it's like if you guys if someone else
likes anything about us it's like yes
you're welcome like could I marry into a
Jewish family and be fully integrated
and accepted you can convert Liam
McSweeney is a journal okay she
converted okay
you can just convert see white boys
Jewish if you're Jewish
you can have me but a lot of people do I
have been noticing this more like
everyone's like data Jewish man which I
obviously agree with because that's what
I'm doing but I am surprised that that's
like catching on and people are more
like I meet girls and they're like find
me a single Jewish guy like that's how
that's more common I'm realizing do you
notice that
um Annie you said this is a common like
I think people have Jew Envy a lot and
but I grew up in a very Jewish
neighborhood but I was brought up Quaker
even though I'm obviously a little a
little Jewish were you uh were you the
only Quakers in your neighborhood yeah
we were the only Quakers in the
neighborhood and then um
yeah we like everyone was Jewish so we
had ju Envy but I don't I mean I don't
know if there had been other people
around us if we would have had but yeah
no we were like wanted to be Jewish
everyone was Jewish what else would you
like to do as a like if you're a Jewish
person I want to go on Birthright I know
even though I owned even though I'm too
old and sorry [__] she was preaching to
the [__] uh about Birthright yes I
would love to have gone on Birthright I
think I was Jewish enough to do it too
and I just I didn't want to go I was
scared of Israel
you Bobby Bobby went on some weird like
kind of like Israel funded not
Birthright but basically the same thing
where they bring in like celebrities to
um Woo is that the word Wu and he came
back like oh my God like it's the
greatest I had such a great time he was
there for like two weeks I want to go so
bad all my Jewish friends would come
back they'd be like not pregnant but
there's always a pregnancy scare they
would tell me about they were like
riding camels they all had boyfriend
like everyone had so much fun on their
birth rate wait can I be weird and tell
you guys about a dream I had
I know that's the word I feel like I
need to hear the dream before I can
answer whether
I so when I was in New York I went out
to dinner with like a group of four
random hot women that I met how'd you
meet
new friends yes like they were at my
show but like we were dming it was like
this like model and then
we didn't like get to say hi at the show
and so we like randomly like almost like
a flirtatious texting led to us like me
sexting making a dinner plan and like
these girls were so cool loved them have
not followed up or seen them have not
heard back that's correct but last night
I had a dream about one of them that she
was pregnant and it was from a random
hookup
and she texted the guy
I'm pregnant with like celebratory
emojis and he didn't write back and she
like didn't understand why and I was
like
you just texted a random guy you hooked
up with that you're PR like I don't know
it was just a very emotional dream now
are you telling this to us because you
want to text this to her and you're just
seeing yes it's an okay thing to text
this could be your your back your end
again a dream it's a little your judge
your judgmental of her in the dream I am
because I'm like
could you imagine hooking up with a guy
a random guy you get pregnant and then
you're like
I'm I'm pregnant like heart emojis but
why is why are there so many aspects of
you because these are all you you really
do want to get a girl pregnant theory is
that that everyone in your dream is just
a different aspect of yourself I'm
liking this okay so who's the model
so it's like excitement and you have
been saying a lot that you think we
would like our dogs more than our babies
yeah I think you're making some mother
decisions well I've also now that we're
connecting dots a little bit I'm I've
been working a lot on a bit about like
wanting to get pregnant it like and have
to take the morning after pill like
wanting like a mistake pregnancy so
maybe that's it but why is that girl
involved and I don't know well she's a
hot girl so you admire her yeah the
number one thing you like
yes sorry I'm American
you guys 30 million women are impacted
by weakened or thinning hair and if
you're among them know that you're not
alone it certainly happened to me when I
turned 30 I got off birth control my
hair just started coming off in clumps I
panicked
um thank God I've found neutral sins I
love that they don't promise an
overnight fix this is something that
I've take that that I've taken every day
for the past couple years and it really
really works I have all the women in my
family on neutral fall nice me and my
sister-in-law are looking for rash and
as neutrophils powerful ingredients
bring your body back into balance you
may also notice improvements to your
overall well-being including more
restful sleep less stress and better
skin and Nails neutrophil is the number
one dermatologist recommended hair
growth supplement clinically shown to
improve your hair growth thickness and
visible scalp coverage neutrophil
supports healthy hair growth from within
by targeting the five root causes of
thinning stress hormones environment
nutrition and Metabolism through whole
body Health they also have a hair
Wellness quiz that is you can take for a
personalized product recommendations
that are unique to your hair needs and
we've all all three of us we have been
taking neutrophils since we started this
show and I feel like it's the one
product we all agree on and swear by and
like you you say you always you're the
one that taught me this like it's not an
overnight fix it may take six months and
that's how you know it's legit this is
not promising I'm soaking into you in a
clinical changing in a clinical study 86
percent of women reported improved hair
growth after six months neutrophil has
three unique formulas to support women
throughout all stages of life including
postpartum and menopause each formula is
physician formulated using natural
drug-free medical grade ingredients and
consistently effective dosages so you
get the most reliable results 3 000 plus
Top Doctors and stylists recommend
neutrophil as an effective and high
quality solution for healthier hair you
can grow thicker healthier hair and
support our show by going to
neutrophil.com and entering the promo
code trash to save ten dollars off your
first month subscription this offer is
only available to you as customers for
unlimited time plus free shipping on
every order get 10 off at nutriful.com
spelled
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l.com promo code trash
this episode is brought to you by simply
spiked summer is when you get to be your
real self so cool off with the only
spiked lemonade that has real fruit
flavor simply spiked it's the summer
drink crafted with five percent ABV and
five percent real fruit juice squeezed
then concentrated and with four bold
lemonade flavors and four refreshing
Peach flavors Summer's getting juicy
with simply spiked 21 plus only contains
alcohol you guys this is actually a
really refreshing drink and I'm usually
picky with what I drink especially in
the summer and I love that they don't
just have Peach they have kiwi Peach
they have mango peach and they have
strawberry peach I feel like I'm looking
at my DMs over there I feel like they're
drinking my DMs peaches wait Kyla what's
your favorite flavor I love the Kiwi
Peach that sounds so good have you ever
gotten a peach Emoji sent to you
um I can't answer that
the appropriate
and it's not just any Hard Lemonade
simply spiked lemonades ready to drink
spiked lemonades broke the internet when
they dropped four bold refresh
refreshing flavors last summer get real
with signature lemonade strawberry
lemonade blueberry lemonade and
watermelon lemonade all with a taste of
real fruit juice Summer's getting juicy
go to drinksimplyspike.com trash Tuesday
to find out how to get your hands on
simply spiked lemonade and new simply
spiked that's drinks simplyspiked.com
trash Tuesday flavored beer naturally
flavored with other natural flavors
simply spiked Co Milwaukee Wisconsin's
celebrate responsibly simply spiked is a
trademark of the Simply Orange Juice
company
is this comfortable how you're sitting
around using core strength oh this is so
comfortable so knees to my chest is to
me equals blood return to my heart so on
the plane I cannot have my feet down
when I sleep I don't know how people do
it how do you guys sleep with your feet
down
like I feel like I'm gonna pass out I'm
like sitting up like this how do people
sleep like this no I can't do that
either but I sleep which I've been told
is very bad for you but I can't stop
myself on the stomach like
like this like yeah like a person like a
chalk out line of a dead body
oh you're just doing baby like belly
time speaking of Reddit enjoy that one
oops like with my ass perched out
there's no way it looks good right now
um how do you sleep fetal or I was
sleeping on my back but then my sleep
apnea it's like I can't excuse me I do
have a little sleep apnea I'll discuss
this are we getting a mask no no no it's
not there do you need to come over and
try days I will never I will never I
would rather die
that no you shouldn't choose that choose
oxygen Annie choose air no with my
clostronic they're just making all these
like correlations between like breathing
and sleep and stuff some
I started sleeping on my side but I have
to sleep on my left side because if I
sleep on my right side you can get acid
reflux and more like GERD and stuff I
think left side is always like again I
always think left side of like blood
return to the heart I don't know wait
that's correct or bad supposed to be on
the side because I'm good good I always
think of left side as like the good side
to lay on even when someone isn't like
in a medical emergency my my gut is to
be like oh lay them on their left side
okay I've also heard that your left side
is good like if you eat too much at
dinner and you're still feeling it like
left side is good for digestion is that
true no sleep with sleep apnea with
sleep I'm a YouTube watcher
I'm not a doctor
uh with sleep apnea a lot of times it is
like there is some like acid reflux
happening too
that's causing your
that is a real thing and it's giving you
like indigestion in your nose which
making your mouth open just making your
mouth breathe I would love to hear you
sleep I could diagnose you well then
let's keep talking
keep this up I'll pass out anytime I
want to I want to watch you sleep I want
to listen to I want to have a
stethoscope let's do a sleep study a
person but let me tell you on I've
already told you this on the plane I
fall asleep immediately my mouth is a
Gabe I look like my parents need to make
a very tough decision about whether
they're gonna unplug me or not it's how
do you sleep how do you know that it'll
be a tough decision
oh
we'll have to call and see if they pick
up
so I have to bring my feet up or I use
those little foot hammocks on the plane
I don't know how people like
do we know about that not all flights
have those no USB ring your own it's by
own house
wait really yeah it's a foot hand
they're like so cheap on Amazon we throw
up a little foot hammock I need one I'm
getting that's a that's that feels good
just like oh my God they don't come in
your size a little toddler too [__]
funny you attach it to the back of the
food tray and it basically just allows
you to bring your legs I mean the fact
that Esther and I 100 thought that
Hawaiian Airlines just had this specific
thing for well because some seats have
those little foot rest things yeah the
kickstand yeah a kickstand thing yeah a
foot hammock okay baby that seems like
it would really relieve the pressure on
my lower back oh my goodness not to
sound like a 35 year old but I could use
that
[Laughter]
did you see the dog hammock up there
it's up at the top
oh that's for clipping nails
yeah I thought it was just to be funny
haven't you ever like picked up your dog
a little early from the groomers and you
see them in that Contraption they just
look like and you're like by the way
Randy's legs are so long he'd be and
then his feet would be dragging on the
ground he'd still be standing oh my god
um I love that damn dog so when you guys
just like stand in place you don't like
get dizzy
it hurts I don't like standing in place
like not moving like walking hiking or
whatever just standing in place you
don't get like light-headed
I don't know if I get lightheaded but
I'm not kidding you I hate standing in
place I would and I hate walking slowly
we got the right outfit for that like
physical baby I would much rather be on
a long walk that's like way too long for
me than just having to stand still same
same no 100 and another thing when you
get up from a seated position
um do you see things right away or does
it take about 30 seconds for your vision
to I think you have low blood pressure I
know I do and I probably have pots but I
think I've been in denial for so long
because I'm only starting to ask people
if they've if this isn't I just thought
he was like oh everyone doesn't see them
there's 30 seconds when they get up I've
had that when I'm lightheaded it just
means like my blood pressure is low and
I haven't eaten enough or something yeah
but I have a thing where when I if I've
been sitting too long and I stand up
like I'm
I'm your joint pain that again is how
you walk it's every time you do like an
example of a weird walk you do it's your
100 walk-on but that's why like I'm so
stiff do you can you just like get up
and be when you do yoga how does it are
you good at
um the half pigeon
yeah why are you very flexible though
yeah because I feel like that would make
your ass not be so diapery while you
walk no I'm very flexible there but also
I think I'm over you I'm breaking up
with yoga it's too much the once a week
have you guys heard of this doctor like
this Fitness Guru Dr Peter attia
so he's like I think he has his own
podcast and they've heard him on a lot
of podcasts he's like
just like Fitness Guy Doctor like he's
pretty smart I'm like a fan now um but
he was on the goop podcast this week or
a few weeks ago and I was just listening
to it and he said that he does something
it's called like
rocking or something it has some weird
name but where he walks for an hour with
a heavy backpack like intentionally like
puts a lot of weight in the backpack and
he lives in Texas and he walks at the
hottest part of the day for an hour with
a backpack and I was like that sounds so
horrible and he's all about like
longevity and stuff but I'm like that is
kind of the most masculine form of a
workout and that's why you grab on to to
Dave's back while he walks and that's
why ride is black
um so basically he's like a David
Goggins type maybe but all over kalila's
she's like I don't know enough about
both of them does he tell you to get
after it Esther no he's not like that
he's I'm telling you he is more like
factual and doctor-like
in not the bad ways even though I know
Dr Miller so high noon with the heaviest
amount of weight on my back in Texas
okay and that's maybe that's what you
know gives people certain like if that's
what they're into great but that just
seems so not enjoyable High Noon the
world is not even pretty outside I can't
no I personally am like that I can't
even go outside when it's the hottest
part of the day like no less walk an
hour with a heavy backpack it sounds
insane basically did you want to you
know does he want to make you kill your
inner [__] no he's not like that I
swear no are we sure
I'm pretty sure the fact that you're
starting to file these like Extreme
Fitness starting too so weird starting
to well starting to open up about it
wait can we um
can I see you in a cold Plunge
funny you should ask
um in New York Dave and I did an
experiment where we ran a very cold bath
because I figured that's a good starter
point and I got half a foot in before
screaming and Dave was like just [__]
do it he was getting mad I can't do it I
can't can you yeah no yes
I think Annie is probably the best of us
because I'm very cold intolerant like I
I just don't do well in the cold so I'm
probably with you like it would hurt me
but that's kind of what it's about it is
about that it sucks I know but yeah
there must be something about being like
petite that makes it harder right
there's nothing special about you
nothing different just like everyone
else I mean yes that's what that's what
David Dawkins would say to them get up
and do it
um I mean yes because you have a lot
less body fat than someone like me the
smaller tub get her smaller tub
um so you know maybe we'll bump it up
like three degrees I would love to
though the way it's talked about online
it sounds like everyone you'll feel so
good afterwards these like maximum cool
benefits it's like from something that
you don't have to take a drug like that
sounds amazing but I lit I can't do it I
like sober Esther again
she's back Esther how have you been
feeling since you got off weed I did you
feel any type of withdrawal did you do
it slowly did you taper off I did not do
it slowly well I did a two-week break
over the holidays and then I did another
month break and wait over the holidays
you were really depressed yeah I know I
was so depressed I couldn't get high oh
okay
um and but you were depressed that you
couldn't get high or you were too
depressed to get high too depressed
again what started off by I was sick and
then like I used that as a way to like
take a break but it was that time it
wasn't that hard because I got into it
like through a cold and then the next
time it was really hard I think I was
telling you this maybe but like I was
having digestive issues like constipated
could not sleep could not like
not only they couldn't fall asleep but
like couldn't like stay asleep in the
mornings like would wake up in the
morning and not be able to fall back
sleep whatever when you quit yeah uh but
now I am I think it's like
I was giving myself so much like blame
and shame for wanting to like do weed
every night and then I remembered I was
like out walking in New York one night
and I was like
every single person in the city right
now is at a bar getting drunk and it's
Tuesday and I was like oh yeah people
drink people like have fun and then I
just decided I didn't want to be so hard
on myself and so like it's okay for me
to get high a couple nights here and
there right yeah yeah yeah I just am not
able to do a couple nights I go too hard
so that's why I don't do it at all so
then what do you have as you're like
substitute for that like because most
people go home from work they want a
glass of wine like do you have something
like that
I just really try to like meditate and
stuff it sounds so lame but there's no
nothing else there's nothing else I have
I'm doing uh I have a ketamine treatment
after this
oh exciting something is it um do they
give you um IV or intramuscular no it's
like a Los Angeles at home like over
Zoom no [__]
that's how fun I'm kind of jealous yeah
I'll tell you how it is yeah
yeah it's like a lozenge and then you
have
there's like I picked out
the person that's gonna sit with me like
what their creative learn stuff at
school I love that yeah mine was not
like that it was like when you get the I
am I think within 45 seconds you're in
the Moon
I'm like make it stop it's like too late
do you still do the ketamine like the
sparingly use it on your own no and
why'd you stop that
I'm I couldn't I just with cluster
headaches again
um eat or do anything really yeah so
cluster headaches kind of like wiped
yourself but I wasn't really doing it
anyway I was already like kind of ready
to stop doing anything
but I stopped weed so long ago I haven't
done weed in so long and done weed
that's how long it's been I say it like
a mom you're saying it like me now but
um
yeah I never feel sober because I'm
crazy and fun didn't understand like I'm
like do you know who's nuts oh [__]
George Kimmel what we had because Bobby
was filming in Hawaii so we were there
for like a week together recording tiger
belly and basically he's like hey like
is there anywhere on the island I can
get acid because I want to do it on the
plane ride home oh
I'm like are you kidding me George I was
like if you would why don't you just do
it in the company of like your friends
he's like no no no no he's like You're
Gonna Leave This beautiful place
he wanted to do acid on the [__]
plane no he didn't but I'm like dude
this guy really gets after it he wants
to kill his inner [__] it's always the
people that are like really like look
like they live a straight and narrow
life that like want to go the hardest
when you let loose yeah and it's always
a people like me who seem like I would
like be such a party girl think of coke
on you at all times right no I think
that's the most accurate description of
like
I I honestly look like I would just be
like a really coked out [__] but I I
don't I'm so terrified of drugs but then
you have George Kimmel who's like you
know this and he wants to do acid on a
five-hour flight I like that all right
George wait do you have your like what
do you have get home from work at five
o'clock wanna kick back and open a beer
and wine nothing maybe food yeah yeah
food's a big thing for me but I do drink
once in a while you do I really really
love Mezcal I like we did it on the live
I drank yeah was that to kill her Moscow
from my belly button I I really was on
my phone you know like on your phone you
have a lot of old like Safari browsers
and I saw one that was like can you get
drunk through your belly button
yeah better days if you guys weren't at
the live show Esther what happened did
you take a shot off to my belly button
you took a shot out of her volleyball
and I felt this and I felt the alcohol
like seep in and I was a little buzzed
we gotta throw her in a cold plunge now
the skin and the belly button is very
thin that's an opening essentially what
did Google say
they never tied you off when you were
born
[Laughter]
it costs extra hours that's what she
does when she goes home to Chicago
behind the couch
it's your G-tube that's how you get fed
together
oh my God yeah no I did mushrooms with
the cluster eggs but it's like there's
no joy in those anymore someone was oh
Josh Potter was like I have all these
mushrooms I was like I'm good
I cannot [__] do that still haven't
done them but I will like micro dose
never I heard that in like it's looking
like in 2024 2025 it's gonna psilocybin
will be legalized it's legal in DC
you can buy it you can buy mushrooms in
DC at a store
that's incredible I know they had that
in Portland which makes sense for
Portland isn't it so weird it's in DC
and I could be like maybe that's what's
going on with Joe Biden
that's why he's talking about
blueberries all the time you know what I
was thinking about Joe Biden you know
how like presidents famously like at the
start of their presidency versus the end
they look like they've aged 30 years but
like with Joe Biden he has nowhere to go
it's so scary to think about what it'll
look like at the end
oh my goodness
but um not to
um toot my own horn but I think I am
probably one of the funnest drunks you
were from the world
I don't know I this is why alcohol can
be dangerous or has been dangerous for
me because I am you didn't watch Friends
you were Seinfeld girl right thank you
um do you remember fun bob the episode
of Friends where I think it's like
um
um anyway there's a character named Fun
Bob and everyone loves him and he's like
the new boyfriend that he's that's
introduced to the group but they find
out later that he's just an alcoholic
right and that's why he's just so
lovable and kind of like
um oh I do remember you remember him yes
um but that's such a funny storyline I
am I've kind of never really had
um
like you know people black out and they
get into like crazy [__] and then people
like you should never drink again yeah I
always get the opposite reviews you're
like you're so [__] you are you're
amazing
and our live show when you were drunk it
was so fun but I wasn't drunk drunk
spitting out the that nasty [__]
dental dam
there's no damn big enough
that's Dental damn next week on the show
For Old Times Sake
um what was I gonna say about drinking
oh
listen I'm I was very fun my friend Abby
was like she's like I love you I'm so
glad you quit drinking but I do want to
say that look drinking with you is the
most fun I've ever had in my entire life
we were getting pulled out of places we
were like unfortunately [__] you there's
this Puerto Rican guy with a lazy eye
I'll never forget like I was like back
off all my girls we were just like find
people to protect us while we're acting
crazy
yeah it was fun fun girl Annie yeah
yeah but then it was like checking for
teeth and stuff there was a lot in the
later years there was a lot of blood a
lot of blood is that why you have fake
blood just like remember remind me it
makes me feel at home yeah
it's so pathetic to have a one pound
weight
why I've you I have this that's just of
course did you ever do that
this is her her Yoni egg did you ever do
pop physique
still around I don't think so yeah and
it was the thing they blew up in like
the early 2010s of La I kind of want to
do a bar class again too I'm getting
back into classes everything everything
like that died in covet is coming back I
know
but this is Carnival Cruise anyone no
thank you
but smart enough to have um bought some
stocks when it went all the way so
regret not doing that I do the idea of a
cruise is like my style like on my trash
it's like a mall you know there's a
casino on it but then you get on here
like this just the fact that this is
where we're at and that's it what do you
mean like you're just like I can't
there's a parameter of where you can go
you're like essentially your your
um Jim Carrey in that movie you know
what I mean like a Truman Show you're in
The Truman Show like you can only go so
far right the the boat is as far as you
go except did you guys see triangle of
sadness yes
I began as my hero so funny my freaking
hero who am I yeah when she has the
freaking she catches the fish
Abigail's a Filipino lady who just no I
remember yeah yeah yeah but which one
are we
I'm Woody Harrelson when I was drinking
I think I want to be the like the hot
girl the model the model yeah the hot
girl model yeah and then I'm the
boyfriend that [__] her yeah do you
know who you are you're the um there's
the guy the captain
who has seen how they they go into this
whole like um communist versus yeah like
that whole deep conversation they have
on the boat that's you I love him what
Woody Harrelson or the other guy the
other guy wait did you guys see the menu
yeah I did kind of similar Vibes yeah
not as good but like fun they I saw the
preview for it it's like I wish I'd gone
in completely blind but I did like oh
the preview like gave stuff away yeah
just you knew it wasn't just like a fun
but I'm so John Leguizamo in that movie
hey everybody did you see that guy
notice me
life I felt it and like I would
definitely still like keep my assistant
that was stealing from me the only thing
the biggest problem I had with that
movie is why he had to go on such a
tirade against s'mores like there's
nothing wrong with s'mores they're not
classless they're I want to put you I
want to [__] put you between two
pieces of chocolate thank you you're the
marshmallow I'm gonna squishy
um
but cruises are have you been on one
yeah I went on a mother-daughter Cruise
you went on a mother-daughter Cruise
because my dance teacher got a job as a
dancer on a cruise ship so a big group
of us went like well it wasn't just uni
mom yeah no it was a group of us and it
wasn't your mom's idea no
[Laughter]
absolutely
more time together
but there was I like Dan my dance
classes were in a neighborhood that was
like much wealthier than the one we
lived in and there is uh we'll never
forget a mother daughter that went on
the cruise like we flew to Florida we
get on the CR from Chicago to Florida we
get on the cruise and then there's a
note on their door that says I'll never
forget Too Close of quarters we'll see
you back in Illinois so they flew there
and then left because it was not nice
enough for them my mom and I were like
we could like um it's just something I
couldn't believe like what are you
talking about as like a you know a
low-class peasant but then okay so did
the cruise take you somewhere because
the cruise I went on I went on
shiprocked that's where I met Papa Roach
oh my gosh
um and they took us to Cabo but it was
just like an island built for the cruise
which I was like ew it was just like
nasty it was like a Harley Davidson and
a Margaritaville I was like what the
hell it's all just like extended out to
a tiny Island I was like probably like
all like Sammy Hagar kind of yes it was
and it's like all the people that worked
there I was talking to them I was like
do locals come in they're like no it's
just Cruise people like what a [__]
nightmare what who did you go with
I went with it was Big Jay oh this is
like a dog show Oh okay that's cool now
as a kid I don't think my family's not
like my mom like isn't wait now were you
constipated on the cruise probably no
because you know we talked about this on
a previous episode where they add stuff
into food so it kind of serves as like a
laxative effect so that they don't clog
the pipes on the boat so did you like
you know take note of your I don't
remember but I always was I mean my
constipation was very much alive and
well in high school constant I'm gonna
call it constant
and after my dance teacher got that job
obviously my dream became to be a dancer
on a cruise ship and I auditioned once
and you should go do that it did not go
well I would I don't tempt me if I could
do your job if I could get the job I
would do it no you there's no way you
can compete against Filipino
entertainers you can't cruise ships are
Filipino entertainers that's like one of
our biggest Imports is like
like entertainment right we send them
off into the UAE to become
um you know
performers on cruise ships and bars
whatever you cannot out dance a Filipino
I don't think after and I believe in you
I think you're an amazing dancer you
would have never gotten that job I
believe you yeah I've never seen you
more strict
and now that I know that it's in your
blood
and we have this are you is this a
dance-off being plotted here what do you
mean no no no no oh no I think we need a
dance off no there's no way
we either need a cruise ship themed
episode I don't know what we dress like
but we need to do it we just all get
seasick or we like Carnival Cruise Polo
uniforms you've got to stop at the polo
uniform I'm never gonna I've got plenty
lined up and locked up loaded in the
closet waiting for you oh my God every
episode's like UPS themed it's like oh
my God go get a job [__] go get a job
yes
we have to do that okay wait she's like
how about we work at Chili's do you
think we have a market a big enough
market where we could do one trash
Tuesday Cruise
set set sail in the open sea
what a have a cruise yeah our own trash
yes maybe we can do the European version
yes
and you go through the islands and you
go to Greece and that I would rather do
I don't want to go to the one that just
like yeah it's like a slug I don't want
to go to the one that just parks in
outside of Ensenada right and they're
like here walk out and look at the
blowhole the whole thing's so weird
yeah here's the thing unless we're going
through some like cool fjords or
something and seeing like orcas like no
thank you or Alaska
I have heard an Alaskan cruise can be
lovely but from who
I need another sword my dad he's never
been on one it would be heard it from
someone else
yeah um yeah you would have to drag me
I've never been on a cruise but I'm
pretty sure you guys would have to
almost poison me and like drug me
together we'll give you some uh
we have your permission on camera now so
we're good
little devil's breath you wake up
pregnant with Esther's baby we don't
know what happened I really wish there
was a Titanic themed Cruise oh my God
where it's like things go wrong and you
know maybe you know it's so annoying I
Would Be Jack and you would like
[Music]
Professor is part of it like poverty
porn where you want to be in like the
lower levels like and be like Jack it's
not poverty porn I've already been on
the lower levels I'll draw you naked
yeah no it's more it's it's like
like a cruise where something goes wrong
and they say we've had an iceberg and
we're not sure and you know some of the
people on the ship are actors sometimes
they're suicidal some of them are actors
yeah some people are actors it's like
Tina and Tony's yes yes yeah escape room
you know
anything like that but yeah you know I
um your dreams are big they're smaller
local things you can do I'm doing too
big
I wrote uh like a six page letter and
actually mailed it to Leonardo Dicaprio
and I had spent like months now after
Titanic came out and I had dried all of
these flowers you know when drying
flowers was a thing I'm so upset and you
smashed it and then it took me like I
think two months to get them like
perfect and I I wrote up this amazing
letter and I even quoted the movie
talking about like there's only like ten
dollars in my pocket which I didn't even
have in my pocket and I remember
spending saving all the money that I
recently earned from like winning gold
as a swimmer
and for the Philippine national team and
putting setting aside a certain amount
so I could mail it to America because it
was 24. when you're a kid I want a dance
contest once what was it I don't think I
wanna it was before the grease Musical
and I won a free t-shirt I won in a
landslide though wait so was it you
didn't sign up for it you just were
there and they're like kids come up and
dance yeah oh yeah no I and when I say
Landslide I really mean it and now I do
want to though go back to kalila I know
I was gonna leave it off the hook for a
second no no actually what kalila is
telling us right now you need to confirm
with me it's sadder than anything I've
ever said that is worse than any poem
I've ever heard
wait so I might yeah what did you say a
reply what did you say in the letter for
10 people there is a line in Titanic
where he tells rose that I have is yeah
like basically 10 cents in this box how
did you get through that I told him who
I was what I do what my dreams are why I
really like him what part of the movies
really like spoke to me that I have a
poster on my bed doing this for a second
how old were you I was 12. okay as a 12
year old
are you trans age you're a 12 year old
as a 12 year old boy yes from the waist
up yes I am
um
as a 12 year old
nobody really has much to offer you were
an award winner you were uh so she had a
chance
you had a shot you were a little old for
him but
um but he was only what how old was he
at this time how old is he now
I have no clue I think he's only like
eight or nine years older so that yeah
maybe um and then I told him that one
day I'd have these braces off that I'm
gonna be I'm gonna grow up to be really
pretty maybe not right now but I
promised him I would be pretty as soon
as my braces came off you promised
Leonardo DiCaprio would be pretty I mean
you you came through on the promise hmm
okay cool that's very sad so you wrote
this letter with the intention of it's
not the letter it's the flowers it's no
it's the letter you don't think it's the
crushed flowers that was really though
to give her credit like that was of the
time everyone was doing that would you
send it to I didn't send them to anyone
because I knew better I didn't have
confidence no but my sister was drying
like she hung dried flowers in her room
and then I did it to copy smash them in
the middle um between books oh yeah or
like put them in tape like uh what's it
called the thick would you have signed a
letter too
well you never sent fan mail any of you
guys ever send fans I did look at her
face mine was you're gonna this is so
Estuary how I did it don't worry what
you found their house broken
I was in their basement for three years
somehow I didn't cook for you and stuff
made them fold your laundry somehow in
the 90s internet I stumbled upon a site
that told you like which celebrities if
you mailed them would send you back a
signed headshot and so I wrote to those
celebrities but I think the only one I
was ever successful with was Barbra
Streisand but she's she sent back to her
fans a signed headshot do you think she
did
am I breaking your heart right now
honestly knowing Barbara do you know her
wow New York was fruitful
okay
I do think it was her because those old
school classy classic stars like they
take I have assistance they take their
stardom very seriously and I do I could
see Barbara signing headshots like every
morning for an hour I could see that
well yeah she signed them but do you
think she was like got your letter and
then was like I'm gonna send this
absolutely not no okay because I was
like this is the deal I have to break
this heart of this delusional the
delulinous wait do you guys know this is
my favorite pop culture fact of all time
I'm like getting the chills just
thinking about it
Barbra Streisand
do you know what's in her basement
my mouth is watering but no my my mouth
is watering
she has a replica of a shopping mall in
her basement so she can like walk down
to her basement and it looks like an
outdoor mall with little shops and
boutiques and are people working there
that I don't know
can you imagine your own play pretend
Mall
I think I feel like every young girls
had that fantasy for sure yeah look it's
oh Barbra Streisand I love the way Fancy
no no no
he's a fancy way of guessing people's
spells
basement
Mall
shopping yeah
she's so Vegas like like look at this
candy shop I remember one time when I
was little My dad's friend
um who's a drug addict got into a car
accident and he had to go to one of
those he had to go to a nursing home
and we would go visit him and in the
basement there they had like fake um ice
cream shops and stuff it was really fun
that's so sad thank you
wait they let you into the how did you
sneak into the the nursing home the
nursing home yeah let me in I'm ready no
I know I would have loved to move it
moved in like this is the coolest you're
the only person like loves the nursing
I'm like I can't wait
scoop your own ice cream no my
grandfather went to like a really nice
retirement home and I loved going there
did they have like perks no there was no
there was a Billiards room that I really
liked I really enjoyed like a library
dark Library Billiards room type thing
because I liked the game Clue
so I felt like I was in the game Clue
okay murder mystery dinner and on the
books let me tell you thing on the books
um he I remember they had like a red for
the stairs they had like this red carpet
that went up it and they had these like
those polls that was like keeping it on
I thought that was like so elegant and
cool it's just old people
and the dining room had um
had like veal with a mint sauce I
enjoyed eating being with the elderly
and eating a baby oh cool real no it
would do okay you guys saw the shopping
mall and you agree it's the coolest
thing that ever exist yes but for NADA
to exist for longer than one week you
know that's like an event thing but to
just have it there what is it doing
she's collecting dust
she's fake shopping down there well you
could say that about everything is
collecting dust but to go to go to the
fake shopping mall
well you're Barber you're a star you
can't go to the normal malls so she
hires people to pretend she makes her
own Truman Show yes are your that was
one of my favorite
um
celebrity couples this is Barbara
Streisand and Andre Agassi
they were together they were together I
know I just always imagined her being
with what's his
she was with Andre Agassi for a couple
years she was always at like courtside
at all the grand slams didn't he date
Brooke Shields too
um I'm not sure but now he's with Steffi
Graf oh really yeah they've been they
have kids like they stayed they're like
lovers forever
graph is a German
um
um tennis player my
who I would have sent letters to
is not someone that's still around we're
listening
I think I brought him up on this show
before and I would love to see where he
is now because I believe he is a cult
leader I hope it's not Andrew Keegan
again
I think that was like a lot of our I was
so attracted to him I was like so but he
lives in Venice and he got busted for I
know the church illegal kombucha but I
don't I don't feel the way I felt now
when I look at him but God I was like
when he was a kid I was like he's so hot
I know what you mean he has Dave hair
wait what was he famous from he's hot I
remember him he was in um there was a
show called
it was only like one season there were
like little things I caught him and he
was also in 10 Things I Hate About You I
Hate About You but by then
I got Camp Nowhere was where I was
obsessed with her Camp Nowhere was my
[__] movie he did you watch Camp
Nowhere no but that guy's hot as [__] I
would have loved Camp Nowhere except
actually no you like parents
it was about like not having parents but
can I just say this I you know men
really love to talk a lot about how they
age better and women don't talk about it
they're just sitting around talking
about it no I've heard guys have said
this to me like oh it's too bad it's
harder women don't age well manage
better but by the way women say that too
and it bums me out when I because it's
like that's something I've heard women
say like even I've heard myself say that
yeah no because we've been like trained
to believe that I think these guys are
like sitting around in like a basement
Mall yeah having a fake tea they are not
allowed in Barbara's Mall
um but I have to say when we look at our
Teen Idol boys they they don't look hot
anymore so it goes both ways
that's all yeah like Devin sour but
Devin sour is not bad I'd love to have
him on this show I think he still sleeps
around
he was high up there you get all these
people before you know we're getting
older now people are oding and [__]
anyway we gotta get him while I'm still
single so I can sit here and squirt in
my panties
oh my God it's so sad when they pull the
pictures of these like old starlets that
are like just not actresses anymore just
living their lives as just regular women
probably happy yeah fulfilled and it's
like why are you putting they're not
they're not doing anything why is the
paparazzi ticket they're like putting
pictures of Bridget Fonda like let
Bridget Fonda live what are you doing oh
that's right because she's married to um
Danny Alpha yeah Danielle she quit she
quit acting she's just like a regular
woman and then people are like look at
how Tara it's like leave her alone
actresses are regular women too what's
that
no she's not in this she's not in what's
that what's that that's so something
that a Grandpa would say to any response
to anything I could not believe what you
were so I'm like what's that lad well
I'm just like what angle are we going
for here [__] I wasn't a jtt girl were
you a jtt I was never
no I I think we all had similar taste
when we were younger because I was a Leo
girl obviously from Titanic were you not
I was a Leo girl from
um uh Romeo and Juliet
I told you I stole I went into the I
actually think this is one of the worst
things I did as a kid besides egging
Robert danieli's house sorry Mrs daniele
um but I went into my library my local
library and they had like the magazine
section and I just stole all the
magazines and cut them up and put them
on my wall that's like so crazy because
that means that like now if I went back
they're not there do you know what I
mean it's like that was an archive of
magazines that would have existed
forever
and I stole them I'm sure that that
happens more than you think I think it's
a very forgivable magazines
um
wait what was I gonna say what did you
just say stealing magazines Leo crushes
Romeo and Juliet library library oh my
God Romeo and Juliet I really like the
libraries a lot for a girl who
I had nothing to do inside them
except collage
I was like send me to the books with the
pictures you would love the Skokie
Library we recently updated it and now
there's a whole we did with the
taxpayers there's a credit taxes there
uh oh Hester got her IRS still an
Illinois resident we um there's a craft
room that has 3D printing and so I you
would you'd love it you'd have a lot to
do no 3D printers that's a pretty fun
thing to do yeah um I recently learned
that you know what howler monkeys are I
do but remind but it's they're just the
loudest loud monkeys right yeah it's
like so [__] loud you can't miss them
but I recently learned that they have
like the tiniest dicks of like all the
primates oh that's so cute but doesn't
that correlate like the loudness with
the size of I'm very loud and I have a
huge penis she proves it all wrong no I
also like my big pianist boyfriends were
very very loud really wouldn't shut the
[__] up they were so loud and they the
world needed to hear them and they had
to sling their [__] around all the
ladies oh I said there's no correlation
then to humans so you're saying big dick
dudes are the loud [__] I think just
people are louder they're not I think
it's more about what who listened to you
and who didn't when you were a kid
really my favorite thing is when a
dude's like super humble and kind of
quiet a little bit of a Wallflower and
then the biggest
those are the long game big dick guys I
love the ones who just like look like
they couldn't ever make you come but
then are so good because they're super
nerdy like nerdy boys always surprise me
because you think that oh you know
they're just you know this and that and
then they're just really great and
studious that's why it's good for
everyone to keep expectations low on the
outside
low expectations in the streets and big
dicks in the shoes yeah
I have a question have you ever had good
sex the first time with anyone like the
first time you've ever had sex with
someone has it been like oh that was
actually like good or has it always been
like some fumbling some kind of like
weird awkward teeth banging I think good
but only to an extent like where it's
good because it's so fun and exciting
because you like the person oh wait I
should ask this have you ever had great
sex the first time
really Annie
I
was worn down so hard it was like I mean
I was worn down like this was like
months of this guy coming into my work
and I was like he was hot but he was so
stupid he was so dumb he was like a like
BMX bike kid he just had like brain I
was like are you okay I could see him
like
like his brain working to form words and
I was like I don't want it and he was
just like I don't know I always had a
thing where when guys hit on me it like
offended me I was like you did this with
all the girls like when Todd Todd first
came over to my house he brought um
which is so cute he brought like Toll
House cookies to make or
and I was so I was like do you do this
with all your dates and he was like no I
was like okay I don't know why I'm mad
when you said that you get offended a
guy's hit on you it made me think of a
different version of that which is my
favorite thing I've seen you do or
you've told me about where like when a
guy hits on you and you're like are you
like you're offended it's like no
and if there there's something you know
what it was it was like when I was
younger my older brother's friends would
like hit on me and I thought that they
just felt like they had an advantage
like they just assumed they could hook
up with me because they were older I
don't know I always was like I just
didn't like guys that thought that they
could hook up with me because it felt
unsafe it felt like they were just like
okay so you're telling me
actually I I think you're correct it is
possible to have amazing sex the very
first time I it was like this guy was so
stupid that everything else was crazy so
by the time you guys got together it
felt like he took me okay this guy
he had like a like a truck that was like
on monster wheels okay and he was so
[__] hot though homeless Julian oh he
wasn't homeless Julian yeah but yeah no
he took me like into the Arroyo and like
drove me around he showed me a good time
he showed me a good old country time was
his sex amazing because there was an
emotional connection on her no there was
no emotional connection there was Zero
emotional connection
it was like I was in shock what he did
to me I had dumb guy sex once and it was
not good it this was I mean I've had bad
dumb guys okay this was like I don't
know but I he it wasn't I didn't go I
didn't go back for more you didn't wow
it's just like
oh okay yeah yeah but also it was like
uncircle I don't know there was a lot
you eat through your pH off so it wasn't
my pH off
I mean it probably could have worked out
but he just was so stupid I hung out
with him like one more time
and I think I told you this he like yeah
like he was like running I had my motor
scooter and he was like running next to
my motor scooter because he wouldn't he
wanted to ride it but I told him he
would have to like ride on the back and
he was like I would never have a girl
riding will never drive me around on the
motor scooter it's a healthy boundary
yeah but um yeah we just I think I've
only had one of those just one one time
where the first time was exceptionally
good tell us more
um he just knew what to do yeah
sometimes people just know what to do
he's a great luckiest he was experienced
he he was really good at you know eating
a girl out he was really just good at
everything but he's like it's more than
just that right it's like the energy of
someone when they're in the bedroom he
is his energy was just perfect he was
calm he was confident and he wasn't a
creep he wasn't overly aggressive he was
just there
for like I don't know something really
awesome I ended up falling in love with
him because it was that great who is
this secret recent I ended up being
obsessed with him
obsessed but this is um don't act like
you're trying to figure it out you're
just mad she's like if I look like I'm
thinking I don't see I'm crying
um we'll bang it out but I think with
Todd too like Todd and I had really good
sex in the beginning because
first of all he's just so cute and it
was like he kept coming over to my house
and not making a move and I was like
that I'm just so that gets me I'm over
like I was like because I dated that guy
before him who was like I don't know if
I had like told you I'm sure I told you
everything but he would be like I want
to be the girl and I want you to be the
boy and I'm like I'm the [__] girl
like it was like you have to like he
didn't want to like put himself out
there to like make moves he was like I
want you to make moves so then he's in
the position to reject me I'm like no no
no no no and he would say it like out
loud he'd be like I want to be like I'm
like you're not the girl I'm sorry
you're sure why did he say that did he
say why he wanted that he just was like
he was like it's so annoying that I have
to be the guy and you guys get to be the
girls I want to be the girl oh he just
was having an identity just listen he's
I he's a very he's a great guy wait so
you're saying that Todd took a while to
make he took a while and I was getting
annoyed because I was like oh my god do
I have another girl like a girl and then
but he was scared because every guy that
that hesitate because every guy most
guys do hesitate to hit on me because
obviously
they always tell me why and it's always
that I basically said like I hate when
guys hit him like I basically said like
do not do the things I want you to do
thinking that I'm talking about a
different you know what I mean like not
them you know I didn't even occur to me
that they'd be like hey but every guy's
always like you know you were like I
hate when a guy does this or that I'm
like oh okay
um that makes sense so Todd was like
afraid and then he
um
he asked like this girl that we were
that we were both friends with he was
like can you just like see
when she wasn't sure yeah because he
didn't we worked together and stuff like
how far into the hanging out was that we
had been hanging out for a while I would
go complain to him about other boys like
I go on a bad date if I were you and he
wasn't like it took a while I'd be like
gushing no exactly so then it was like
so yeah and he was yeah he Todd did like
a thing where he like crawled on the
ground like [__] Leonardo Dicaprio
and and uh what's it called in that
movie you know what's the movie
Wall Street yeah it's like crawling to
me it was cute he was so cute
yeah he was very I know hot it was
really hot yeah I mean she said cute
because he's you know
I am with you though that like the
longer a guy takes to make a move it is
just like amazing and they're like I
assume he likes random you're like wait
does this [__] not [__] like
me yeah am I getting friend zoned
yeah because it's it's just
it's so it's like a really I'm honestly
so horny no it's like right now my jaws
it takes it right away too and it's like
that's what I want no no because then
it's like it's just so obvious that
that's what they wanted to turn off
right but for like the these are I'm
telling you these are two people that I
had great sex with the first time one
I'm gonna marry and have kids with and
one I [__] once and he gave me
bacterial vaginosis right but you know
what I mean yeah
okay so I think you're on to something
it's like let me earn you a little bit
because I'm somebody who like I get my
like
I've gotten a certain level of like male
validation like my whole life it's not
hard to come by it hasn't been like
historically hard to come by so when
someone kind of just holds off just a
little bit it dries it makes me so
uncomfortable it's a pattern interrupt
too yeah exactly
they make you uncomfortable yeah because
she's not it's a person who is like
telling I'm so sorry Esther as someone
that has recently fallen into this it's
been like this always and it makes you
uncomfortable if a guy doesn't like you
if if you're not getting like
yeah like because I've been a boyfriend
girl my whole life I've there's never
really been a time where I haven't been
this is into you or somebody's into me
some I know that I can if if
I screamed out the window someone would
come running do you know what I mean
like you kind of have that you're like
you know like I know I could [__]
tonight if I wanted to I know I can have
whatever fix crack whatever dopamine hit
I need from a [__] guy but when
someone is just so like what Todd was
which was like I'm gonna take my time
I'm not fully sure yet it just drives me
into like a level of horniness that like
I can't even like like my jaws are
tightening right now thinking about it
pause
do you also have this
um for lack of a better term
entitlement to male validation
like do you I this is I need to know
this because I did not ever have this
like you just said have you always felt
like not always but I always knew I had
something going on right I was like
getting molested about like teachers
exactly something going on like
everyone's driving it's true people that
weren't supposed to be trying to [__] me
were trying to [__] me so not that you
feel hot from that but it's like and you
know like I knew myself as a sex object
and by the way it's not always well it's
not necessarily attention that I wanted
some of it but a lot of it was very
negative a lot of it was not like a
positive experience saying like oh I
know a boy likes me sometimes I'm like
oh yeah
I don't know of course and it's not bad
too wait also this makes so much sense
Annie that when we first met I felt like
we were so similar in our personalities
like we had so much in common but the
way you are able to reject men
it almost felt like a foreign language
to me like when you would like truly
when when a guy would hit on you and
you'd laugh because I didn't look at it
as like a finite yeah of course you're
like I I gotta keep this I will never
forget that it's impacted on me forever
like that you laughed at guys who hit on
your like no if it's mean though it's
also me and it's like no but guys that
mixed signals the guys that it was it
wasn't mean they were mean guys I think
I remember who you were talking about
now and it was so crazy it was so
outrageous see it was outraged look at
her how'd you do it how'd you do it no
we're I was leaving the comedy sorry
just first of all I just come from the I
just got past the comic store by the way
right away
um hello no one else and it's also guys
the types of guys we're talking about
guys or guys who've like made me feel
very ugly about myself yes no but it was
I mean I thought it was a joke I was
like are you gonna be [__] kidding me
wait how'd he ask we we're in we're like
hanging out of the conversation first of
all I'm at work you know like obviously
we're all friends but I'm like
like if if you're a comic and I'm gonna
go with you like it stars must have a
lot like it has to be a whole thing like
it can't just be this guy like it was
like are you [__] kidding wait you
were dry I remember I was driving yes I
was driving to whatever street I was
sleeping on at the time my little rent
direct that I [__] lived in I rented
like a Plymouth Neon that was all dented
and I would just park it near my friends
houses and sleep because I kind of knew
the neighborhood
but um I don't know where I was staying
at that point but I was driving to it
and said comedian who by the way he
pulls up in his prayers is this Bobby no
oh my God oh my God that's so insane by
the way if you think I would have told
you that day yeah second I spoke to on
FaceTime when I first get friends with
you
um
there's no secret time also that's
enough on the details but also by the
way Bobby would have been we don't need
Prius Bobby would have made sense
this was like
what do you have to
offering and
um he we stopped at the light and I
thought there's like a joke you know he
rolls his window and I go like oh hey
like we were just hanging out and he
goes do you want to come to my house and
make out and I was like
like ew are you kidding like it was so
surprising to me that that person would
think but Todd said this to me goes he
goes Annie I want you to know every Open
Mic group secretly thinks they can [__]
you I'm like that is so annoying because
my whole thing since I was young was
like I hate that when people think they
can I don't like people being entitled
to be able to [__] me or thinking that I
would just [__] them or I'm easy or I'm
just like this object for them
and so when I see the caliber
I always thought it was a higher caliber
now I go oh it's just all of them it's
just every single one of the things I'm
buying you know I actually once had a
moment like this that I'm now
remembering that there was a male
comedian that I like hung out with a
couple times like we went out for you
know dinner whatever just like usually
it's so normal super normal like we're
peers right and this is when I was
living in a studio apartment with an
with another person and I he like was
asking me about it and like because I
think he was in town visiting and so he
was staying at a friend and I was like
oh yeah like I share one room with
another person uh what a treat as a as a
young female comic to have not a place
for them to try to ban you in what a
good excuse but so then he I had no idea
that's where this was leading but so
then like after I had explained that to
him he was like oh I guess we'll never
be able to make out then and I just it's
just like that's what you thought was
happening here I was so grossed out and
that was probably the only time in my
life of ghosts someone we never he's our
peer I've never he's our peer it's never
been addressed
I'll tell you after the camera this kind
of just brought up a really [__]
terrible memory for me oh no really now
we're laughing
I once dated somebody oh no
when we broke up
um and he still had keys to my place
um
was took revenge on me when he found out
that I had been with somebody else like
after our breakup by bringing a girl
bringing a girl to my place to [__] her
and you know what his excuse was he's
like well she lives on a boat so there
was nowhere to [__] her and I was like
what about your place these themes today
I am capable of murder for that okay and
for a while best thing to have someone
in your ill is that is that like
criminal yes he broke into your place to
have sex and I remember writing the girl
and being really nice about being like
hey girly next time don't use my place
as a [__] pad like being really polite
too but obviously with some bite into it
but I'm like not blaming you for his
behavior but also like
she knew who I was to like is there some
type of girl code where she would have
been like wait this is your ex's home
and I know who your ex is like some
people are very hurting they're very
broken inside and they're not aware of
that when I got hit on did I talk about
this on here recently when I got hit on
by the by a guy in a Hollywood guy whose
wife is like such an icon like such a
like
I couldn't be a bigger fan it's like so
offensive I'm like why would you think I
would ever ever ever
have anything to do with it yeah like I
would be using you to get to your wife
anyway
um and my heart is still breaking I'll
get him telling that story let's go back
to talking [__] on Comics
I'm sorry that is really traumatic
that's really evil someone did something
really evil to you I'm sorry
you're right I why am I like she's not
okay I'm really not okay like I'm like
how long ago was it and long enough that
I should be over it but like I it still
like hurts me and I'm like this and I'm
like well it's gonna continue to be
friends with just everybody like it's
okay everything's forgiven but I'm like
oh I'm a spineless [__] person well
no you're coping and you're you're just
you're coping and if it's in like a
friend group and stuff and you're just
trying to kind of like get through it
and also sometimes forgiveness is for us
not for the other person every time
thank you thank you I feel validated I
think I was very enraged in that moment
and maybe just tried to Black it out but
also the thing though it's not just like
who cares about like the sex and stuff
is like a completely separate thing it's
like someone like came into your space
that's so scary
because it was somebody that I like
loved once upon a time and like even
going back to my place was like where
did they [__] did they [__] on my couch
yeah
think about the origin of those actions
though was like out of he was in pain he
did it from a place of pain and like
so at least that's something that's a
win no I think I understood it at that
time yeah I was like oh this person like
must have felt really like hurt by the
thing that I did which was like move on
a little too soon you know until that
happened but yeah he got us every time
you sit down you're like is that wet
that's like
hell yeah that's violating his [__] it's
so nasty yeah but it's like even like
how do you feel if someone house sits
for you like there's certain people I
would never let like I probably wouldn't
let anyone really in my house but
there's a comic in New York who I really
like he's funny but he was like can I
stay at your house and I was like no
like I would rather literally pay for
you to get a hotel than you would come
to my house I have boundaries now I love
my home it's my family's house like
you're not going near I don't want you
near my plants and [__] wait that's a
really good move that I've done where
it's like I don't want them in my space
but they're coming into town I will get
a hotel room but you know what I also
love didn't do that because I was
thinking about that and then I was like
you know what if you're not if you don't
have enough money to figure out where
you can stay then you shouldn't be
coming out here yet you should save up
when you can [__] afford your place
because it's like why I'm like
the you know I can obviously help people
when it's the appropriate thing but
anyway then he goes I go I'm actually
out of town that weekend because I was
and he goes oh then let me set your
place I'm like the [__]
what would have to happen in the world
for me to let you jizz up my beautiful
apartment like gorgeous
no really I would let him stay oh really
yeah I have had guy friends come over to
my old apartment no they would take
pictures of my dirty underwear ew I know
I'm like that's so trying to embarrass
me I'm not gonna they're not trying to
embarrass you
they're trying to masturbate to your
dirty underwear later I don't you think
I think you have the opposite thing
because you were like yeah yeah we have
we do have opposite instincts there yeah
I think everyone has always been trying
to [__] you and you just haven't noticed
whereas with Annie and I it was
noticeable because they were usually
molesting yeah the interesting the
rapage that you said is how you had
older brothers whose friends tried to
[__] you and that's I think that's like
why you don't like older guys and
whereas I had an older sister who always
had hot boyfriends who wanted nothing
that's why I like older women
do you like older women no well yeah
couple years how many years three
examples that's not what I was saying
well you mean you like guys because of
no like my exposure to like the older
teen boys was that they didn't like me
and you're and they were gonna hit on
you because they were dating or yeah I
just had a thought that's blowing my
[__] mind Esther you're gonna be 40.
what and I can't imagine you looking
like this and still be and and be 40.
I'm I look like a real a 12 year old
who's really tired that's how I'll look
the same just tired this is insane yeah
and your mom looks so young yeah she
yeah but Annie you guys are the same
thing no I think we were afraid not even
believe my it's so weird I'm so excited
to turn 40 but I like it's so weird I'm
here it's like so wild you don't age
yeah I never get incredible it's weird
but if I had kids I might have aged
sooner I think they suck
um but um they do the juice wait did we
agree that we were all gonna do
um microneedling together because I got
it what place is it
it's you're just it's small punctures in
the skin plus laser um Annie can't
perform mine on me
I'm gonna use my micro dip
that'll do would you be into that why
not
Esther's like things she'll try are so
weird they just always involve someone
vaginal vagina well
micro needling and what what questions
do we have for the audience in the
comments this week
are you do you assume people of the
opposite sex are into you or not into
you
also guys are not into me sometimes too
I'm not saying every guy's into me but
no of course not but you've had very by
saying that you have options your whole
life means that men have made it known
to you have like communicated it yeah
there are things happening again yeah
okay I know who would you guys or who
did you write a Like Love Letter to what
celebrity did you write a love letter to
um we love you Suggs we'll see you next
week with a brand new episode bye guys
[Music]
foreign